Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to five nights at Freddy's Help-Wanted
VR (Virtual Reality)
I am a...
Brave boy.
I mean, I'm a brave man. I am a brave man. Not a boy...(suuuuuure)
I'll punch you-- What the fuck?
What the fuck?
Wait a minute. Am I-?
Am I- I swear to God I saw a face behind that bunny like on the wall back there.
No, no, it's the way the texture is I'm sorry, okay.
I'm very sorry about that.
For some reason the texture on the wall behind that bunny back there. It's just so dark and shadowy.
I thought...
Euh, I thought that was a face. Holy shit!
Anyway...
So we're going into "Dark Rooms" because it goes from Five Nights at Freddy's 3,
To Dark Rooms, to Parts And Service, to Vent Repair,
and I don't want Vent Repair or Night Terror so I'm gonna go for...
"Dark Rooms," whatever this means. Doinkus.  It's kind of plushtrap esque. So this might. Whoa.
Wait, stop plush- Oh, so this is the mini game!
Ohhhhhhh. Okay, it's the mini game okay, You little shit-
Well come over here. oh, come-  come to papa! Uh do do do
Oh! Where are you?
What the- Oh Uh
Wait my hand, ho, oh oooh that one interesting.
Alright, get ready to draw! Three, two, one
Huuh!
OOOOOHH
Nice dick! Okay, where you gonna be huh?
Where you gonna be?
Huh
Alright
Yeah that's what i thought
HUDUSHCUS
Okay, all right, well, let's take a look around the room first, whoa what the- whoa, okay
What the hell?
Whoa. Whoa. What the? Wha- What? Whoa. Hey, ho! whoa, whoa
Whoa you-- I--
You're not supposed to move when I- What the fuck? Where'd you go?
Boy, it's all-- what's that about? What the?
Oh shit
Oh- Oh my god
What the fuck?
Whoa, Hey, Heyyy! whoa, what the fuck?
What's with that? What is with that?
What the fuck is with this?
What is that? Whoa shit? Hey, hey. Hey, listen, you little shit. Okay, you little piece of shit. Alright, whatever
Yeah come on. Try me. I got a fistful of fuck and you got a face full of fis- fistables!
Oooooi! Hey, where are you running to little bunny?
*Grunt*
Ooh
Gyoo
Aghh!
Okay, alright not a lot of time, uuh, okay fuck. uhh, well I screwed this one up
Eh!
Shit
*Mark screams in terror*
What the fuck?
Eah, you little piece of shit. All right, you think you can mess with me? Huh? I got two punchers
Ooo, You think that you gonna mess with me? I don't know what the fuck that door was about, but holy shit. Okay?
All right. Okay. All right, Loodadoodadoo
Ooo, Let me count my fingies
HUWAGAJA
Eheheheheh
*breath in*
One, Two, Three, Four, Five.
Bwaaa! I heard that
C'mon you, you, I got a flashlight here. Whap! I'm gonna to whap somebody.
Somebody's about to get whaped.
Heh! heheheh I see you ok come on, ok, I got a tube here a tube of light.
Oh- Ohhhh, Heeey, buddy
e
Hoooieee
G'bye, alright
I'm gonna getcha this time
Hoh huh
Hoo, Eyyyyy
Hahahaaahahaha!!
Ya little piece of shit you think you can beat me the answer is you can NOT. give me my price I hope its something 'Punch-Able'
Oh, Wow, I thought I got one a you's already, didn't I already gets, one a you's, you're dumb looking! ahuhuhu
You're all so big but that doesn't mean I can't Boop you on your snoot, a doinkus. Hey, come on
Stop that. That's my most sensitive snoot. Oh you mean this one a boinkus. I mean it.
I'll hurt you real bad, if you do that again. Oh, you'll hurt me real bad. I'm sorry, here-
It comes three two one. Psych out. Here
I comes! boink. Ohhhhh-
WRARARA!!!
Alright, your dead now. That bits over.
bye~
All right, cool. Good, great. I got that prize. That wasn't so bad.
That wasn't bad at all.
Right. Okay. Well, that's great. Hey, do I get to do the same thing with-
Nightmare BB? Cause that sounds awful. I don't want to do that.
Pull on triggers stop on the X, okay?
All right. Okay. All right.
Oh, you are worse, I don't like you, okay. All right, what's behind the door?
WhaH!!
Don't you laugh at me? You little piece of shit. You Know Who I am. Oh, yeah. That's right. You're not so little
Hello?
You're not so little you're not as little as I thought you might be-
Dwa! ah, okay alright okay, okay, okay.
Okay, alright you little shit.
How-
What the fuck? Who you? Who you wanna run that by me again with the; What the? What was that?!? Hey. Ohhh...
Hello, hi. Okay. Alright, give it more patience
One more time.
ha! hehehe
You're big oh, uh, okay. All right. I don't like that don't like this at all Oh
ah, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, fucking oh my god
Fucking stop it, oh
Whoa! What the fuck okay, whoa, okay. Last one, let it go, let it go
Whoa! Holy shit. Oh my god.
Fuck. Me....
(Whoa 4X)
Whoa, okay, there was no need for that ever.
Yay! A FazBar!
That's good in my tum tum. Okay. All right, Jesus Christ.
Okay. All right, escalating a little bit here. I don't like it. But what it is. Hey buddy how are you doing?
Okay, all right what plush baby wait
But that's but that's over there dude, the  plush
I don't know what this is even gonna do. It's
Gonna be the same Oh push and hold stick pull trigger
Survive until 6 wait, what am I doing?
Wait, what am I doing?
*unintelligible* What does that even mean? What?
Wait, what am I doing? What what am I doing? Oh,
Oh, fuck oh god. Wait. Wait. What the fuck? Okay. Wait
Wait, there's a I need this Oh
What the fuck? Wait. Hey Oh Oh God. Oh my god. Oh, are you kidding me?
Are you oh my god. Wait, wait. Wait. Oh shit. Oh, fuck. Oh! Oh god. Oh god. Oh,
Fuck me. Oh fuck me. Fuck me
Oh, fuck me. Holy fuck me
I'm gonna die. Oh fuck
Sorry about that, okay, I'm not gonna die. I'm not gonna die because I'm just not oh
Okay. Okay. Okay. Let it charge, let it go. Let it go. Let it go. What a
flying fuck
Is this shit about?
What in the bitch ass?
No
Why what who where and why who and where and why AH!  fucking why?
What
Nothing can are you yeah, um, yeah about that. Yeah about that. Yeah, I don't yeah about that. Um
Yeah, I'm not so sure about that
Okay, so maybe they can only spawn in specific spots right down there perfectly understandable, they go in the vents sometimes
There there's a vent over there something up there. Okay
That was over to that where was it where was it?  I'm not seeing where it was. Where was it Oh God
Where is it?
No, I don't wanna do- DON'T! STOP STOP STOP
NO- NOOOOOO
Where are you? Where are you?
Where are you?
Wait, ok, hang on. If it's-
You go in the vents Oh up there. Oh shit, okay. Alright good good to know
Okay, so they can only be in so many places
at once
Where where is it? Okay, that was a bit.
Oh, what the fuck Oh, what the fuck? Oh, okay. That's good to know. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on, go. Go go
where are you?
Where was that? That was somewhere
Where? What the fuck? oh god, I'm gonna die. Okay, I am gonna die. Wait, ah, I see you, okay
Got it got it got it
Oh- AHHHHHH
*sigh*
Fuck...
Okay
Okay, fine, yeah, this is all fun and games until this started happening
You go away. If you're gonna go away, I've got some time where could they be?
Here there, ah 'er ya are, okay
Gotta charge
Let it charge
It sounded like above, okay
Ah!
Let it charge okay
I got this just gotta find him. They are there
She is there
She's somewhere. Okay, where i'll see? Oh, we got a problem. Well, where where was that? Where was that?
Where was that? Oh, fuck me, how
What that's open now?
Where- ahh
Okay there you go, ok give me charge, give me charge, give me charge
Ok...
So they can only be
So, uh, hello you can only be in so many places at once it's good to know
Cuz I just gotta look- ah I see you. Ok, I see you
Ok. I got this on lock
So this is fine.
I got this.
Oh who did that?
Where where was that where is that? What Oh, why ball? Why ball? Wait, wait, wait, wait, where are you?
No, no, no, no I got that one
AHHHH! FUCK! FUCK! FUCK!
Fuck.  my flashlights got cursed
Fucking hell. Oh my god, that's so hard. That's so hard
Okay, you're not gonna get me this time you little shits
Yeah you little shits. Yeah, you think you can get away from me? There's only so many places
You can be I just gotta check all the places where you could be and that's eliminating all the possibilities
Where oh there you got it, okay, please tell me that it's not gonna kill me.
Oh! Right there
Ok.
Sweep the bottom
Sweep the- Oh, what the fuck you were just there what you were
You were, ah! There you are
Ok, alright
Sweep the bottom. There you are
Ok.
Where where where ah, there you are
Oh fuck oh fuck
Okay, so there can be multiple ones at any given time that's what I'm learning about this, okay
I just need, a little more, time
Ah!
ok, ok
Uh, Ah!
Ok good, good, good
Wha- where? Where? Where where no no, no there!
AHHHH!
Did I get it I got it okay, I got it. Okay. All right a little more
Ok, a little more
Ok, there you are, I see you there
There you are
No, I don't know I don't know I don't know I don't know I know there you are
That's okay little more a little more a little more. Come on
Now
Gonna make it. Okay. Oh
No, no..
Oh, I'm fine I won!
Right, okay where everything's good
Is that an original
1982 Lithuanian lard!
Oh my god! This is the most exotic butter I've ever seen.
1982 and its pristine
Lithuanian lard went extinct and in (in, in)
2004. Oh my god.
I could know myself. Okay, big part my hands gone. Narrator: We hope you're enjoying the fazbear virtual experience.
I am please be aware that there may be visual artifacts left behind from the beta testing phase of development-
If you see any such artifacts we recommend that you not(do not) interact with them.(Oh)
We'll weed them out eventually. (There's no guarantee that we'll weed them out eventually.)Alright, Okay. All right. Thanks. So the visual
Artifact being my hands or what? What do we?
What do we get chatting about over here?
What are we should chat about? Okay fun time whaa-!?!?!
Hey, wait. Hey, wait. Wait, hang on a second. I that down like the thaa
I don't like the look of that. That's good. Okay. All right, then let's do it
All right, fun time foxy it is then huh?
Okay. All right move thumbstick. Wait excuse me?
Hold trigger to use flash beacon cross the room. No
No, no
No
No, you don't understand. No, I'm good. I I don't no no
No, no, you're talking some bullorashit over here. And no I I don't want to do that
that's awful that this is
Funtime foxy is motion activated Oh for this reason
It's important to keep the room dark as to not accidentally activate her
Wow
You have been provided with a flash beacon use it if you need to get your bearings and to ensure you don't bump into anything
Oh, however use it as sparingly as possible Oh proceed forward to reach the parts and service room Oh
Oh, fuck me. Oh no. Oh no
Oh no, oh no
Fun times
Motion activated for this reason
It's important to keep the room don't think I don't know
However, use it as sparingly as possible sparing proceed forward to all God's answer. Oh hi
Okay. Alright, that's great. That's wonderful. Okay, so that's what I'm dealing with great good to know
I'm gonna there's some okay great. Nothing can harm me
You know what except my feelings and my brain and everything oh fuck me
Oh
There's something over here
This shit, okay just look hang on this just oh
Okay, I don't get it yet how this is all working oh
Man oh man
All right fine you want to dance bitch you want dance with me, huh? You think I'm afraid of you
What are you kidding me? Are you kidding me are?
You kidding me tink. Yeah, what do you think about this? Let's go this way
Okay, that's too many. That 's too many. That's too many blink *noise* now. We know the limit now, we know the limit, okay
All right. I got this
Yeah, like clockwork
- too soon too soon, okay
Here we are here we are yes, yes. Yes. Yes
Hahaha that yeah, you ain't so bad
Went from being the most monsterous sell chips. Great. Whoa. Oh, did that say asbestos. Did that have asbestos in it?
Did I just eat a bag of asbestos?
I think that might have said it had exclusively asbestos, which I have a problem with cause that's not good for me
Alright, so I'm not doing good on coins. That's for damn sure, but I am doing good on these games
So that was terrifying that was terrifying but now we've made it to the parts and services
Why I don't freaking know and then vent repair and then night terrors which sounds bad?
But probably five nights at Freddy's 4 or something like that
Shit, okay. Alright anyway, so that was that next up is parts and service. So, thank you everybody so much for watching.
Dude, that was terrifying at first, but then I conquered it with my braveness.
So, uh, thank you everybody so much for watching
There will be more FNAF coming at you hot and heavy as fast as I no
No, please stop telling me this do not tell me this that my cam(ERA)
Froze do not say that.
How long.
How long has my camera been down I have no idea
So anyway-
I don't know how long my camera's been down and I don't know why
That's hasn't happened for a long time. But alas here we are god. Damn it. Okay
Hopefully it wasn't too far in but if it was then you just get to experience the dark with me. So thank you everybody.
So much for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video. Bye, Bye!
*Outro w/ mangle jumpscare*